from the strange side-effects of
long-distance relationships that wind up
going fully multiversal to the
challenges of a Super Soldier Serum blow
up here are some pretty weird things
about Captain America and Peggy Carter's
relationship we might as well start by
acknowledging that even in its most
basic form Steve Rogers and Peggy
Carter's relationship is definitely
weird when you compare it to traditional
love stories from Peggy's point of view
it involves a man who dies and then
comes back 70 years later looking
exactly as handsome as he did in 1941
the decades in the middle were occupied
by a long and successful career as a spy
not to mention a marriage to someone
else and two kids that we never even
learn about from Steve's point of view
it's even weirder as far as he's
concerned he goes to what he thinks is
his death only to wake up a few seconds
later to find that everything including
Peggy has moved on into the next century
without him he goes immediately from
promising to take her dancing to hanging
out with her as she's dying of old age
after a long life that he wasn't really
a part of then he goes back in time to
put a ring on it after seeing her on her
literal deathbed he was at her funeral
before he was at their wedding that's
not usually the right order for those
unless something has gone terribly wrong
and then we get into the really weird
stuff if we're going to get the weirdest
and most obvious sticking point about
Steve and Peggy's relationship out of
the way right up front we're going to
have to talk about Sharon Carter it's
pretty clear from the way that the
movies unfold that the relationship
between Steve and Peggy wasn't
originally intended to be the end game
so to speak Captain America has famously
been characterized since his return to
the comics in the 1960s as a man out of
time he's the iconic hero from the
country's past who returns like King
Arthur and our moment of greatest need I
understood that reference the thing is
nobody actually wants a superhero who
needs Peter Parker to explain how to use
his iPhone so cap is also a guy who
acclimates very quickly to new
situations whether he's fighting bad
guys or catching up on 70 years of mist
pop culture losing the years he would
have spent with Peggy is a necessary
ingredient for giving his time on ice
some emotional weight waking up in the
21st century isn't that much of a
tragedy
even talks about how much he prefers
present-day food to whatever he was
snacking on back in the 40s so the only
thing that he really loses his Peggy
even that turns out to only be a tragedy
for Steve in Winter Soldier we see him
as he watches Peggy explained that after
the war she got married to an unnamed
soldier and had a very happy and
fulfilling life working for shield as
Steve's story continues to the loss of
his relationship with Peggy and
eventually the loss of Peggy herself
becomes the one big tragedy of Captain
America's history especially once the
other close companion he lost makes his
own miraculous return from the dead that
also means it's something he can move
past which of course he does right into
the waiting arms of Sharon Carter and
that is a problem as much as we all
might love Steve and Peggy together
there's a pretty good reason why Sharon
shows up in the Winter Soldier to add
another side to this cross time love
triangle in the Captain America comics
Sharon is caps longest-tenured love
interest she even predates any of
Steve's other love interests including
Peggy in fact until she popped up on the
big screen in 2011 Peggy was actually a
pretty minor character who mostly
appeared in flashbacks Sharon on the
other hand was the longtime on-again
off-again romance that always seemed
like the default setting for Captain
America's love life after all if you're
going to have Steve Rogers continue his
adventures in the present day after
spending 70 years trapped in an iceberg
he should probably have a present-day
love interest the First Avenger was
framed as a flashback so Sharon was held
back from the Marvel Cinematic Universe
until the second film since there was
already a character in the comics who
could provide a connection to cap Peggy
got the role of the bittersweet tragic
romance in the first movie unfortunately
for Sharon it turned out to be a little
too bitter for everyone who wanted a
happy ending so cap never really got
over Peggy which created a whole other
problem this all brings us to the really
weird thing about the cap Peggy Sharon
triangle even if they're both age
appropriate due to some suspended
animation hijinks it's usually frowned
upon to date your ex-girlfriends nice
especially if she's about fifty years
younger and then there's the problem
that we get into with all the
time-travel that comes at the end of
game it's all well and good that caps
reward for saving the universe is that
he gets to go back and be reunited with
his one true love but Sharon is Peggy's
niece Steve and Peggy get married and if
you look closely you can spot a wedding
ring then Sharon is also Steve's niece
which means Captain America straight-up
made out with his own niece like two
days after his wife's funeral
sure Sharon wasn't his niece yet and
Peggy wasn't his wife before she died
which is a pretty concise explanation of
the headaches that result from time
travel but still you can use all the
ancient ones magic timeline graphs you
want to explain why it's actually okay
for all of this to happen but even the
most die-hard fan of the Steve and Peggy
romance has to admit that it's weird
that Captain America's dating pool never
really extends beyond his own family one
of the really sweet things about cap and
Peggy's relationship is that the two
characters always carry pictures of each
other even when they're separated by the
Gulf's of time cap has his picture of
Peggy that he clipped out of the
newspaper when we get a glimpse of her
desk in the 70s during endgame we see
that Peggy keeps a framed photo of Steve
even 30 years after his presumed death
in the Arctic what makes it even sweeter
it's a photo of Steve before his
transformation from the Super Soldier
Serum showing us that she loves him for
who he is on the inside and not just
because Mad Science turned him into the
Marvel Universe's hunkiest possible
Chris at the same time that's a little
unusual on its own right isn't it Steve
had to have been kept in America for at
least a few years right
the first avenger opens with the Red
Skull discovering the tesseract in 1941
and it's implied that the end of the
movie happens close to or even
immediately before VE Day on May 8th
1945 even if you give him plenty of time
to catch up on the news volunteer and go
through training there's still two or
three years where he's the Hulk that we
all know and love judging by the
increasing tightness of his shirt over
the course of the MCU it seems clear
that Steve himself is pretty comfortable
with his ridiculously shredded new body
there isn't a big question of who's
Steve's true self is like you might see
with Superman and Clark Kent if that's
the case then maybe Peggy's photo isn't
really for Steve at all maybe it's just
a tribute to how much she loved
symbolism
even at the best of times relatively
speaking Captain America and Peggy
Carter's relationship wasn't easy of
course it had to be at least a little
rocky that's where the drama comes in
and while it might just be nice to watch
two people have a perfectly content
relationship while also destroying
sci-fi pseudo Nazis even romantic
stories are driven by conflict still
most traditional romances don't involve
one party shooting at the other with a
handgun four times when she catches cap
in a super heroic makeout session with a
fellow intelligence officer played by
Natalie Dormer Peggy is incensed even
though she and Steve are definitely not
a couple yet Steve's not blameless here
either he immediately gets defensive and
goes way too far in response implying
that she's getting some action from
Howard Stark it's a bad scene all over
it all comes to a head once Stark
himself shows up and oblivious to this
little tiff gives Kap a prototype of his
famous shield and Peggy unloads four
rounds at him which is the kind of
situation where it's okay to be
defensive especially if you're holding a
bulletproof shield that brings the fight
to an end but is it really a healthy
foundation on which to build a life
together as romantic partners is every
argument that these two have in their
relationship going to end up involving
firearms and vibranium
we do this all day the question of how
the alternate timelines shake out if
Captain America goes back to live a
happy life with Peggy Carter is going to
prompt a whole lot of headaches
especially if you try to make it line up
with what we see in agent Carter
Steve's plane goes down somewhere before
May of 1945 agent Carter's two seasons
take place in 1946 and 1947 that gives
us a couple of options as to what might
happen when Steve travels back in time
let's say he goes back to shortly after
he vanished and gets that dance which
means that the events of agent Carter
don't happen as we saw them that could
mean that Steve tags along his Peggy
super-soldier sidekick which would
actually be pretty charming or maybe
they wind up doing something else and
there's no one around to stop Dottie
Underwood from murdering Howard Stark in
the 40s that means Tony Stark is never
born which means that this particular
timeline probably ends with Thanos
destroying the earth because Hawkeye
tried to fight him all by himself want
to really get weird with it let's assume
that after he departs for the 1940s
Steve settles in for a happy married
life and spends the next 70 years with
Peggy before arriving back on that park
bench as the world's most handsome
hundred year old he might be back where
he would have been without being frozen
in the ice but he's still a man out of
time just in the opposite direction he's
been to the future and Peggy's a spy
there is no possible way that Peggy
Carter doesn't use Steve as a resource
for information on what's going to
happen so that she can more effectively
do her job for shield even if Steve
never got around to getting the
specifics we know that he's at least
aware of a few pretty important things
that happened between 1945 and 2011
because we see him writing them down in
his little notebook he knows that the
moon landing happens in 1969 which is a
pretty big deal he knows about the
Berlin wall he even knows that Apple
computers is a pretty good investment
when it goes public in 1980 and all of
that is just what we know from seeing
that single page in his notebook but
sure maybe Captain America decides that
preserving as much of the timeline as
possible is worth not telling his wife
things that would help her prevent
countless tragedies he still knows that
shield itself has been infiltrated by
Hydra and that his best friend is alive
in Russia being brainwashed into
becoming a cyborg assassin who kills
Peggy's
Howard Stark there's no way that Captain
America and agent Carter don't at least
try to deal with those things meaning
that they're running the risk of
creating a very different time line on
the other hand Peggy would probably get
to try Thai food way earlier than she
would have otherwise so that's nice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]